hey guys I'm Ryan right
oh sorry how the show works so a lot of
people have been saying since we've been
checking a lot of scary videos for the
month of Halloween October people have
been saying to check out for CH and
posts I don't know what those are
it's a chatroom thingy okay well
apparently there's six terrifying 4chan
posts this was sent to us so I was like
all right I guess let's check out this
particular one created October 1st of
the year 2003 the new thousand website
4chan became the center layer for many
Internet servers posts are arranged by
most recent and it's different
categories allow for a wide variety of
this sounds like Canadian Stephen
Hawking fortune has acquired a very kind
of special thing and on many occasions
its users are taking part in incredible
stories okay oh yeah that's where all
the new new big huge engines are
thinking about doing so shocking that it
becomes engraved and the long list of
memories attributed to its community
these are six Harvey's are six
terrifying 4chan posts apart play the
many different personalities that you
can find the fortune it is important to
say that among these can be lurking very
evil individuals
okay there's reason everybody needs to
be aware and careful of how to interpret
what is read okay an anonymous post
suggested a chemical experiment to
create your own homemade fluorescent
light the experiment consisted of three
simply
a plastic bottle a chloride tablet and
isopropyl alcohol all you have to do was
fill up the bottle with alcohol drop in
and chloride tablet close the bottle and
give it a shake little that everybody
knows that what was actually being
created was a ticking time bomb it is
not exactly known if anybody was
affected by this post's and quickly
measures were taken by the moderators to
make sure this post was deleted
whoa I'm not allowed here November 30th
of 2013 MV first gun from a University
in Ontario Canada open up a 4chan post
stating the following this is it tonight
I won't be ending my own life but I was
shattering the last Star Wars making
their preparations and I'm ready to go
through with it as an old member who's
been on 4chan since 2004 I thought I
would finally get back to the community
in the best way possible I am willing to
commit suicide on camera for you all all
that I request is for you guys to link
me to a site where I'm able to stream it
for you then gladly Fuu Jesus something
later and with the help of a few
supporters the college student was able
to set up a stream with a maximum
capacity of 200 viewers the spa's got
quickly filled up some encouraged to
suicide and others strike stopping the
student but the vast quiet maturity just
said and watched the student was seen
taking pills and alcohol he then set up
a fire in his dorm and proceeded to hide
under his bed
the room can be seen getting filled up
with smoke over the course of 30 minutes
until finally a group of firemen break
into the room and carry out his
motionless body the student was taken to
the hospital where he later recovered
oh good number she's a watermelon
teenager Oscar Lopez found himself
searching to his deceased father's
belongings when he suddenly stumbled
upon a hand grenade excited but unsure
what to do with it he created a post on
4chan he showed several pictures and
posts in response to the comments in his
thread just to prove that the grenade
was real Oscar agreed to perform all the
tests that the fortune crowd threw him
in his last post he's shown a picture of
himself all in the grenade by the pin
asking if he should throw it on the
toilet many kept the conversation going
but Oscar would never replay back again
a small investigation revealed that the
posters IP address was from the city of
Guatemala a place where the local
newspaper displayed the death of 18
following a grenade explosion Jesus man
coincidences were just too many and
Oscar paid the price of his Restless
people that pressure you on this we're
going to fight spree during the early
hours of the morning somebody opens up a
simple post with the picture of a woman
that post says the following
if anyone can correctly guess their own
post number I will tell you where she is
buried this is a very popular game in
fortune many participated in the event
until finally someone guessed correctly
when following the correct guess the
original poster congratulated the winner
and posted a set of geographical
coordinates the numbers are real and
many did not expect was
to be revealed the next day the woman's
corpse was digged out from the given
position and that creator of the post
arrested for his murder number two it
all began with a fascinating an
attractive post that quickly became
popular among the thousands of messages
that are created every second and
fortune in it were posed in beautiful
images of crystals and instructions on
how to make them anyone who read this
post must have believed they would be
beautiful decorations or a perfect gift
that post specified that these crystals
had to be homemade the simplicity of the
experiment stood out immediately
although was needed was a copper coin a
glass jar two large tablespoons of sugar
and one large spoon of sodium
bicarbonate the experiment required the
jar to be filled up with bleach and
ammonia a very simple chemical compound
that is found in almost any cleaning
solution the cocktail then had to be
fully mixed with the help of a straw by
boiling bubbles into the solution if the
byblos bubbles inside but within five
minutes crystals would start to form
but what silently awaited the people who
follow these instructions was very
different or was actually being created
was hydrochloric acid an extremely
poisonous chemical it was a chemical
used in World War one to kill people
that it would burn skin tissue and if
inhaled that would destroy your windpipe
and in the worst cases your lungs and
internal organs a few very educated
users were quickly to post warning
messages to deter people from the post
but it was too late
many were affected by the horrendous act
an anonymous user opened up a thread
with the following turns out his harder
strangle somebody to death than it looks
in the movies
dr. loan was a picture of his
girlfriend's lifeless body her face was
pale and purple and red marks could be
seen around her neck
the 4chan community was quickly to react
some believe the pictures to be staged
in a discussion quickly began on the
legitimacy of the post the original
poster responded with another set of
pictures detailing the incident and
wrote the following she thought so damn
hard her son will be home from school
soon he will find her and call the cops
I just wanted to share that pics before
they find me hey buddy BB gun that looks
realistic enough when they come I'll
pull it and there will be suicide by cop
I understand the doubts but check the
[ __ ] news I have to lose my phone now
sometime later after the post police
responded to a call of a son who found
his mother strangled the killer was
identified as David Callan
he later submitted himself to the police
Oh [ __ ] up wow talk about some
disturbing [ __ ] that goes down on this
website
I have never heard of this website I
heard of it because of the new Jennifer
Lawrence photos and Jessica brown
Findlay oh but I don't realize that like
people like it read it sorry my
boyfriend's laughing I was like super
stoked you have to be a special kind of
[ __ ] up person to like encourage
people to murder themselves by accident
I thought youtube comment boxes were
[ __ ] up this [ __ ] is like beyond
something else I've been like it sounds
like people are talking about doing
horrible things to themselves to people
then you got a community of people who
are like in support of such a dark thing
yeah yeah that one probably disturbed me
the most the fact that like so
so many people were cool with that kid
yeah the I know yeah are you in the
[ __ ] video Bridger are you in the
[ __ ] video I said enough to bring
your boyfriend by this is what [ __ ]
happens when someone brings a boyfriend
by you start [ __ ] interrupting the
video it's okay we'll just take some
advice from 4chan on what to do is oh
that's good
come on we just saw a lot of real thing
now we're gonna get okay and one that
really shocked me was the guy who was
like I'm gonna commit suicide and then
there were like a bunch of people who
were totally in support of him do it
because they just wanted to be
entertained support of watching it like
not just like I'm doing it and like in
your mind like talking to something you
don't know but actually like it becomes
real when you watch somebody and you
know it's like the fact that someone
would be like okay I'm gonna like watch
this person kill themselves over the
internet and the serial killers and
stuff it's crazy how there's killers who
out there who really do want the
attention and really want the
recognition for what they're doing I saw
a video five youtubers turn killers so
these are youtubers with followings that
turn into killers
these are like killers who want to have
like a certain following about it it's
like almost you know negative cultish
not positive cultish what cult is short
for a culture Noel so you know you don't
have we live in an American cult
American culture but then there's also
things like Charles Manson's cult which
is not as good as the American Gold the
guy who strangled the the mother and
then the kid at it like geez man when
you destroy one life like you murder
someone you're destroying lives around a
lot of other people I get really upset
when there's like children involved in
stories like that just because it's like
this guy if it was his girlfriend he
obviously knew this kid and
that he was putting that child in the
situation and like the fact that that
child had to like find the body like
things like that make me upset because
I've had friends that have unfortunately
has like found their parents and like
I've lost my mom
so like stuff like that like my mom
wasn't murdered but like I can't even
imagine the shock of being like a young
kid and walking in to that and like how
[ __ ] up that could yeah when my pops
died my sister was the one to find it
and that is she's not even she was like
still teenager it's fine that that's
already traumatizing enough but then I
could only imagine you find out that
they were killed instead yeah fun
channel we have fun videos for you with
fun discussions afterwards
thanks for the suggestion guys now I'm
uncomfortable that's okay you don't
worry deodorant anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the channel you can
subscribe today and become a reject
asaurus no you don't you wouldn't want
to be called a reject or subscribe or
get rejected but if they're choosing not
to subscribe they're not being rejected
I'm the one being rejected subscribe or
reject me you can check out no he knows
not where I know he knows not actually
knows a hell of a lot so check it out
see what I did there that was nice huh
and there's a nice I'm trying to be I'm
trying to be a little nicer to you like
Ryan Ryan idit E that's when you lose
your virginity to Ryan
Cornell Marie hey brother I'm a huge fan
of your channel hopefully I can get on
your level and receive all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] number four
I mean LOL jk he meant to say LOL not l
mm Oh laughing my lips off JK but
seriously man I have a shout-out to my
YouTube page Cornell Marie where I sing
rock covers and [ __ ] and my Instagram
castle underscore corn not a fan of your
Instagram and don't laugh if you hear me
saying I'm still learning just I'm still
learning
lol stay cool brothers you're learning
how to sing and then you're putting you
learning how to sing on YouTube which is
the exact platform you want for feedback
because people are so nice and
considerate and will appreciate the fact
that you they know you're doing a work
in progress so they will be kind to you
they will not judge you if you're off
it's nothing but support on YouTube just
look at the comments on this video
nothing but support as I'm too terrified
to post something on YouTube mad
respective Veronica I just don't know
but he's black though okay so here's all
you gotta do then you just gotta be
tough at the end of your videos be like
you want to talk [ __ ] I'm gonna kick
your [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you get their own
the n-word I can't say that but if you
throw in the n-word man that'd be scary
black subs please defend me and tell me
that you thought this was funny so that
way all the white subs will not call me
a racist
I'm Ryan right